This lecture is about text based prediction.
In this lecture we're going to start
talking about mining a different kind
of knowledge as you, you can see here on this slide.
here on this slide.
Namely, we're going to use text data to
infer values of some other variables in
the real world.
That may not be directly related to the
text, or only remotely related to text data.
So this is very different from
content analysis or topic mining where
we directly characterize the content of text.
It's also different from opinion mining
or sentiment analysis, which still have
to do with characterizing mostly the
content only
that we focus more on the subjective content
which reflects what we know
about the opinion holder.
But this only provides limited view of
what we can predict. In this lecture
and the following lectures, we're going
to talk more about how we can predict
more information about the world.
How can we get sophisticated patterns
of text together with other kinds of data?
It would be useful to first take a look
at the big picture of prediction in
data mining in general and I call this data mining loop.
So the picture that you're seeing right now
is that there are multiple sensors,
including human sensors to report what
we have seen in the real world in the form of data.
And of course the data are in the form of
non text data and text data.
And our goal is to see if we can
predict some values of important
real world variables that matter to us.
For example, someone's health condition
or the weather, or etc.
So these variables would be important
because we might want to act on that.
We might want to make decisions based
on that.
So how can we get from the data to these
predicted values?
Well, in general we first have to do
data mining and
analysis of the data.
Because we in general should treat all
the data that we collected.
in such a prediction problem set up,
we are very much interested in joint
mining of non text and text data.
We should mine all the data together.
And then through the analysis, we
generally can generate the multiple
predictors of this interesting
variable to us, and we call these
features.
And these features can then be put into
a predictive model to actually predict
the value of any interesting variable.
So this then allows us to change the
world and so this basically is the
general process for making a prediction
based on data, including text data.
Now it's important to emphasize that
human actually plays very important role in this
process.
Especially because of the involvement
of text data. And so human first would
be involved in the mining of the data.
It will control the generation of these
features.
And also help us understand the text data
because text data are created to be
consumed by humans.
Humans are the best in consuming or
interpreting text data.
But when there are, of course a lot of text data
than machines have to help, and
that's why we need to do text data mining.
Sometimes machines can see patterns in
a lot of data that humans may not see,
but in general human would play an
important role in analyzing text data
in all applications.
Next human also must be involved in
predictive model building and adjusting
or testing.
So in particular we will have a lot of
domain knowledge about the problem of
prediction that we can build into this
predictive model, and then next,
of course, when we have predicted
values for the variables, then humans
would be involved in taking actions to
change the world or make decisions
based on these predictive values.
And finally, it's interesting that
human could be also involved in
controlling the sensors.
And, this is so that we can adjust the
sensors to collect the most useful data
for prediction.
So that's why I called this data mining
loop because as we perturb the sensors
to collect the new data and more useful
data then we will obtain more data for
prediction.
This data generally will help us
improve the prediction accuracy and in
this loop are humans will recognize
what additional data needs to be
collected and machines would of course
help humans identify what data should
be collected next.
In general, we want to collect data
that are most useful for learning.
And this there is actually a subarea
in machine learning called active learning
that has to do with this.
How do you identify data points?
That would be most helpful for machine
learning programs if you can label
them, right.
So in general, you can see there's a
loop here from data acquisition to data
analysis or data mining to prediction
of values, and to take actions to
change the world and then observe what
happens.
And then you can then decide what
additional data.
Have to be collected by adjusting the
sensor. Or from the prediction errors
you can also know what additional data
we need to acquire in order to improve
the accuracy of prediction. And this big
picture is actually very general and
it's reflecting a lot of important
applications of big data.
So it's useful to keep that in mind
while we're looking at some text mining techniques.
So from text mining perspective and
we're interested in text based
prediction, of course sometimes text
alone can make predictions. And this is
most useful for prediction about
human behavior or human preferences or
opinions.
But in general text data will be put
together with non text data.
So the interesting questions here would
be first how can we design effective
predictors?
And how do we generate such effective
predictors from text?
This question has been addressed
to some extent in some previous
lectures where we talked about what
kind of features we can design for text
data.
It has also been addressed to some
extent by talking about the other
knowledge that we can mine from text.
So for example, topic mining can be
very useful to generate the patterns or
topic based indicators or predictors
that can be further fed into a
predictive model.
So topics can be intermediate
representation of text.
That would allow us to design high
level features or predictors that are
useful for prediction of some other
variable.
It maybe, although it's generated from
original text data, it provides a much
better representation of the problem
and it serves as more effective
predictors.
And similarly, sentiment analysis can
lead to such predictors as well.
So those are the data mining or text
mining algorithms can be used to
generate the predictors.
The other question is how can we join
mine text and non text data together?
Now this is a question that we have not
addressed yet. So in this lecture and
the following lectures we're going
to address this problem because this is
where we can generate the much more
enriched features for prediction and
allows us to review a lot of
interesting knowledge about the world.
These patterns that are generated from
text and non text data themselves
can sometimes already be useful for
prediction, but when they are put
together with many other predictors
they can really help improving the
accuracy of prediction.
Basically you can see text based
prediction character serve as a unified
framework to combine many text mining
and analysis techniques, including
topic mining and content,
any content mining techniques or
sentiment analysis.
The goal here is mainly to infer
values of real world variables.
But in order to achieve the goal, we
can do some other preparations and
these are sub tasks.
So one sub task could be mine, mine the
content of text data like topic mining.
And the other could be to mine
knowledge about the observer so
sentiment analysis or opinion analysis.
And both can help provide predictors
for the prediction problem.
And of course we can also add non text
data directly to the predictive model,
but then non text data also helps
provide context for text analysis
that further improves the topic
mining and the opinion analysis.
And such improvement often leads to more
effective predictors for our problems
it would enlarge the space of patterns
of opinions or topics that we can mine
from text.
As we'll discuss more later, so the
join analysis of text and non text data
can be actually understood from 2
perspectives.
In one perspective, we can see
non text data can help text mining.
Because non text data can provide
a context for mining text data.
Provide a way to partition text data in
different ways, and this leads to a
number of techniques for contextual
text mining.
And that's to mine text in the context
defined by non text data.
And you can see this reference here
for a large body of work in this
direction, and we're going to highlight
some of them in the next lectures.
Now the other perspective is text data
can help non text data
mining as well.
And this is because text data can help
interpret patterns discovered from non
text data.
This helps discover some frequent
patterns from non text data.
Now we can use the text data that are
associated with instances where the
pattern occurs as well as text data that
are associated with instances where the
pattern doesn't occur.
And this gives us two sets of text data
and then we can see what's the
difference and this difference in text
data is interpretable because text content
is easy to digest and that difference
might suggest some meaning for this
pattern that we've found from non
text data, so that helps interpret such
patterns.
And this technique is called pattern
annotation.
And, you can see this reference listed
here for more detail.
So here are the reference that I just
mentioned.
The first is reference for pattern annotation.
The second is a Qiaozhu Mei
dissertation on contextual text
mining. It contains a large body
of work on contextual text mining techniques.